This video is brought to you by
skillshare,
the first 500 people to sign up with the
link in the description.
We'll get a two month free trial.
Greetings and welcome to earthlink
cinema.
I am your host Garrick's,
where amyloid,
this week's artifact is up the film that
mandated the Pixar rules that adults
should cry as much as possible.
The film follows human boy,
Carl Marx,
whose dream is to control the means of
production so we can go to Paradise
Falls,
New Jersey,
just like his hero,
Vladimir Lenin.
One day a homeless girl named Ellie
breaks his arm.
They naturally fall in love,
and before you know it,
she dies just like all great
relationships.
Anyway,
the neighborhood's getting gentrified,
which doesn't sit right with Carl who
knows a thing or two about sitting.
In fact,
the thought of capitalism drives Carl so
bonkers.
He assaults Bob the builder,
and with no other options flees the
country and a pitiful excuse for an
escape pod.
Little does Carl know that a prediabetic
cub scout is stowed away to earn his
badge for the mile high club.
Maybe it's those glasses because Carl
can't see they're heading into a tornado
or why kids love cinnamon toast crunch.
They narrowly survive and land right
where they wanted to go without having
to ask for directions.
Once Karen,
they go the rest of their journey on
foot and take the house with them.
Since there is no valet but not before
befriending a talking horse.
Hi there and famous American actor Kevin
Bacon,
who legend has it was six degrees taller
than everyone in Hollywood,
but not so fast and the furious 15,
a group of other angrier,
more talkative horses all want a piece
of Kevin's bacon because I mean who
doesn't unable to get a selfie.
They take Carl and the scout to their
leader because that's what minions do
best.
They're taken to a Blimpie's where they
learn the Pepsi twist.
Lennon has been in New Jersey this whole
time trying to cast Kevin in a snuff
film.
Carl tells the boy scout not to be a
narc,
but as blood sugar spikes and he blabs
that's my new giant bird pet.
They make a sweet escape.
Remembering that horses don't flip,
but just like my ex wife,
Lenin is two steps ahead and as lit the
house on fire,
Kevin gets burdened down,
so carl goes back to his original plan
of I guess dying in the Wilderness after
two days.
That is until he finds an Amazon nook
giving him the proper motivation to
enter the third act,
a battle royale ensues,
but not without some warmup stretching,
always stretch.
Carl,
let's his house go to and Lennon
realizes he could have learned something
from Kevin Bacon,
namely how to get footloose,
Carl reunites,
Kevin with his bulimic children and back
in the big city,
which has probably been freaking out
nonstop that someone was able to just
fly away using balloons.
Carl gives the boy scouts some tin that
said best.
Extremely heartwarming up illustrates
the dangers of being trapped by
nostalgia,
which wasn't cured until 20,
67 by Dr Millie.
Bobby Brown,
when his fwb dies.
Carl metaphorically and trines her in
the house that they built together.
He keeps everything exactly as it was to
preserve her memory and to keep her
ghost happy outside.
The world may keep trucking,
but Carl clings to the past even though
he may be in the Matrix.
The house itself symbolizes corals,
grief,
which he has to carry with them until
the housing market improves.
Lenin is in many ways Carl's foxy or
counterpart like Carl's condo linens.
Air Ship is a museum of artifacts from
better times like the Jurassic Age and
his mission of Redemption Parallels
Carol's journey.
Eight called me a fraud.
Those should I bring back this creature
and my name will be cleared,
but just as Carl can't bring his wife
back,
no matter how many houses he knocks up,
Lennon can't bring back the glory days
through sniping the snipe.
In fact,
a snipe hunt is a colloquial term for a
wild grey goose chase.
We're in a naive person is fooled into
chasing after something that doesn't
exist like love up.
A poignant message about coping with
grief and a healthy gluten free way.
At first,
Carl cares about nothing besides his
super dead wife,
but as he develops affection for the
scout and Kevin Bacon,
he develops a new selfless purpose that
helps him move on to save the day.
Carl must divest himself of the past by
littering.
When Carl passes on the badge that Lee
gave him as a child,
we realized her memory has transformed
from a burden around his neck to
something positive that he can share
once hobbled by grief,
the new Carl abandoned his walker and
can once again move freely through the
world.
You know what Gabe of proving once and
for all Western medicine was a lie.
The film posits that instead of bold
adventures,
the best pursuits are the simple
pleasures of everyday life,
like enjoying a cup of Joe on the porch
of your spaceship.
In the beginning,
Russel claims he wants to explore
unknown lands and claim them for the boy
scouts of America,
but his happiest moments are his
memories about eating dippin dots with
his deadbeat dad,
I always get chocolate and he gets
butterfree.
Might sound boring,
but I think the boring stuff is the
stuff I remember the most
for all of Lennon's glorious exploits.
He's more alone than Florida.
Mom on sector five at Christmas,
and while the childhood portion of
Ellie's adventure book is full of dreams
of paradise falls,
the mature Ellie filled the book with
Raci photographs of her life.
With Carl.
The moral is to enjoy the simple things
like the love and companionship of a
friend and avoid the bad things like
kidnapping and trafficking,
a minor to South America for earthlink
cinema.
I'm Garrett.
Formula.
Adventure is out there.
Hey,
why's cry?
Characters intern,
Jerod here.
We've got a lot of exciting new things
planned for you guys in the new year and
we can't to see them
and if you've been dreaming of starting
a project or learning a new skill but
aren't sure how to jump in,
then let's he'll share,
help you make it all the reality skill
shares on online learning community with
over 17,000
professional and easy to understand
classes and design,
photography,
business and more.
There are tons of likeminded people with
advice and steps on how to finally get
your ideas in motion,
whether you're a creator or you're
looking to become one.
You can take classes on everything from
an intro to mixing music to basic
character animation to how to make
delicious fresh pasta.
A premium membership is super
affordable.
It starts at just $10 a month.
You'll get unlimited access to the full
range of courses,
but the first 500 wisecrack fans to
click the link in the description or
receive a two month free trial to
skillshare and all its amazing
resources,
so head over to [inaudible] dot s,
h slash earthlink,
forward to being in your two month free
trial and get learning.
We can't wait to see what you create and
don't forget to subscribe and ring that
bell so you don't miss all the great
stuff we've got coming up.
Thanks for watching.
Catch you all next time.